hello everyone I'm here at cube con
Seattle my name is Sal Ollie I'm hosting
today's activities I have Brian grant
over here Brian has been with the
kubernetes project from the very
beginning he's got a very long list of
titles that I have here he is the co
tech lead of Google kubernetes engine
the co-chair of the kubernetes special
interest group for cig architecture
kubernetes api approver he is also on
the kubernetes steering committee and
he's part of the CN CF technical
oversight committee Brian you've been
with the project for a very long time
can you talk about you know where it all
started and where we've come since yeah
I've been at Google 11 years at this
point I feel like I've been working on
this project for 10 years I worked on
Google's internal container platform
Borg before this and he founded the
Omega projects internally and we talked
about communities being an open-source
board it's actually closer to being an
open-source omega'
because a lot of the ideas were inspired
by ideas that we developed further in
omega and some of them we integrated
back into Borg and others were hard to
integrate into board around 2013 when
dr. really started to take off we had
started to work on open sourcing our own
container runtime let me contain that
for you
and when we saw docker really had a much
better user experience we were a lot
more focused on resource utilization
we're gonna talk about this more in our
keynote this afternoon with Tanaka and
Clayton Coleman so I won't give too much
away there but you know it was
immediately obvious to us that this
would be really useful to the world
broadly and you know there have been
some other open source projects in this
area like mesos but we had some
different ideas about what we wanted to
do they were again inspired by our
learnings from borg and our work on
omega
that we thought would be really valuable
to people so we started working on the
Age API design late 2013
eventually the open-source project took
off we open sourced it the initial
project just had four api's pod
replication controller service and I
want to say minion the endpoints API I
didn't even exist yet I think you know
but we knew there would be more and more
api's board also started with a handful
of resource types but it wasn't as
extensible so we really ran into
obstacles trying to add new concepts for
example so we wanted kubernetes to have
at least an extensible concept space
where you can create new resource types
for new concepts so it wasn't actually
super extensible in the beginning you
had to extend it with go code and that's
where we partnered with the Red Hat
folks and who were building
openshift based on kubernetes and we
decided at the time we would just use in
process go interfaces as extensions for
admission control for example for
authentication and authorization and for
resource implementations but over time
we've converted those two out of process
extension mechanisms like admission
reports customer resource definitions
api aggregation and so on dude is really
motivated by a lot of that internal work
at the beginning where we were really
lacking those mechanisms do you think
that's what led to the project success
if not what else do you think was part
of I think that was a big part of it I
mean we knew that just you know the
ability to launch and scale containers
was kind of table stakes that was a bare
minimum but people would need a lot more
than that and indeed it's kind of
expanded into a portable cloud platform
with more than 60 api's at this point so
you can look at cloud providers and see
all the different services that they
provide and people want a portable
version of that that they can run in a
consistent fashion in any environment
and kubernetes provides that to them so
you know as people tried to adapt
kubernetes to more more use cases they
add more features they also make it more
plugable you know do you know you've
been working on the storage systems how
many different storage layers there are
right so the more different kinds of
environments and underlying
infrastructure that communities can run
on the more broadly useful it is the
bigger the community and the bigger of
the ecosystem
and that has this synergistic virtuous
cycle sort of effect where you know more
people are invested in adding value to
the ecosystem is OLOL so it sounds like
being more extensible from the beginning
helped the project become more
successful are there any challenges
associated with trying to make the
project more and more modular yeah so we
have extension points in a lot of places
at this point we have CSI CNI CRI
at the node level we also have the
admission hooks I admission
authorization hooks authentication notes
we have custom resource definitions API
aggregation so there are so many
different ways you can extend and people
swap out hope components as well people
swapped out key proxy the scheduler
ingress obviously auto scalars so making
kubernetes works similarly enough that
people can get that consistent
environment that they value is a
challenge so this is why we started the
conformance program to help ensure api
compatibility and workload portability
across all the different kubernetes
distributions i think we have about 70
now to Bernays distributions and
services that have demonstrated that
they can pass the conformance test and
we're actively working on improving the
conformance test coverage for the things
that everybody uses and depends on
especially for the things that are
highly pluggable in the system because
that's where behaviors are likely to
deviate from one another for those who
aren't familiar with a conformance
program what is the end benefit to users
so the end benefit users is that
kubernetes works the way you expect so
if you pick up an off-the-shelf
configuration for a kubernetes
application or a hub chart it will work
no matter which kubernetes flavor you're
using if you find a tool in the
ecosystem for monitoring your
application or load balancing or
debugging
or see ICD or whatnot it will work
regardless of which kubernetes
distribution or service or multiple
services increasingly you are using
because hybrid cloud is reality multi
cloud is a reality and its really Cooper
Nettie's that's enabling that containers
give you some amount of portability they
let you take they separate operational
concerns from developer concerns so you
can carry the same immutable container
image from development to production
through binary promotion process and
they also run on different Linux
operating systems and in different cloud
environments but if to make your whole
application deployment work you need a
lot more than just that you need
networking and load balancing and
storage for example so kubernetes
provides those additional abstractions
that you need to get true portability or
across the different environments thanks
Dan yeah so it sounds like the
conformance program is got you're going
to help kubernetes users have a
consistent dependable experience so I've
been hearing more and more beyond
kubernetes about new projects things
like stok native can you talk about
those and how they relate to kubernetes
and how they fit into the open source
ecosystem yeah absolutely
and Google started these projects
because kubernetes has grown a lot and
it covers a lot of surface area but we
actually do have a defined scope if you
look on kubernetes do we have a what is
community's dock that I wrote a few
years ago it largely is still accurate
and up to date I simplified it after
last year's keynote a little bit but
really we have the same vision for
kubernetes as we always did which is
it's a base platform for managing all
kinds of containerized workloads so if
you need to do have this additional
functionality like CI CD in particular
there are lots of different opinions
about how to do that I'm personally a
fan of get ops and declarative
configuration but there are lots of
different workflows apt and to integrate
with a lot of different systems
or you know different size organizations
for example may have different workloads
different types of applications written
in different languages or different
application frameworks may benefit from
really highly tailored you developer
your workflows and actually it's getting
easier and easier to build custom
developer workflows on kubernetes
because of how much it provides for you
out of the box like tasks distribution
and execution is a solved problem you
don't have to worry about that and
that's all what a lot of platforms
focused on in the past and even a lot of
CI CD systems and other types of
orchestrators but kubernetes just does
that for you so you can focus on the
kind of the last mile of getting really
a highly tailored workflow so Kay native
raises that level higher by providing a
workflow for these stateless
applications including things like
functions in arbitrary languages because
it runs containers so you know if you
want to use JavaScript like every
functions platform supports that's great
but if you actually have a ruby
application you can run that too and the
idea would be that Kay native deploys on
top of kubernetes and gives you some
sort of server list framework yeah Kay
native deploys on top of kubernetes and
provides some of the behaviors that
people really expect in a service
platform like zero to one activation for
example because it actually brings in
the SEO piece which is the service mesh
which gives you a lot more observability
and control over the communication
between the services so you can you know
that a request is being delivered to an
application you can then spin up that
application on demand that's just one
example and you can Auto scale because
you know the the latencies and that and
the throughputs are the requests that
the application is receiving so that's
going to provide even more opportunities
for automation that exists today and Kay
native is really just the start of that
the one big topic in communities right
now is where to take service discovery
and load balancing and
the future kubernetes has some
primitives some of them like service
have existed from the very beginning but
it has some limitations and is grown
kind of organically well building is do
outside of kubernetes has allowed us to
really innovate and experiment with the
service message approach for providing
l42 l.7 service discovery and load
balancing between applications it gives
you capabilities like monitoring the
request traffic controlling the request
traffic rate limiting even authorizing
request traffic through identity of the
workloads so I think one big one big
challenge for kubernetes right now is to
figure out you know given the rapid
development and popularity growing
popularity of service mesh how do we
want to best enable service mesh in
communities in the future so and service
mesh is designed to work not just with
kubernetes but across also with the aims
and across environments and across
deployment mechanisms I think that's one
of the real powers of that abstraction
and we want communities to be kind of a
first-class part of that and both this
deal and key native you know speaking of
first class I've adopted the kubernetes
resource model as a way to configure
those services right there building on
top of kubernetes yeah they're building
on you know we looked at that and said
look we you know these systems need a
control plane well we built a control
plane and the kubernetes resource model
is being used by now hundreds of
projects to automate and control all
kinds of things so is it fair to say
that kubernetes is a solid base to build
on and as you grow your service or your
application you're going to begin to run
into a set of challenges that sto and
Kay native can actually help build on
top off and solve for you yeah I think
absolutely for newer users they might
even want to start with Kay native which
provides for example a simple continuous
deployment solution designed for
applications like functions you can plug
in your own solution there but it
provides one out-of-the-box
and you can get started using K native
now and then if you need to run stateful
workloads you can go write down kind of
talk about break the glass right down to
kubernetes and run helm charts are used
you know case on it or terraform or
plumie or whichever or just simple cube
controller apply which is what I like
that sounds awesome
if folks who aren't really familiar with
this stuff want to find out more where
would they go so for the kubernetes
project there's obviously kubernetes do
sto data okay native do to learn about
those projects you want to learn about
how Google is including these products
into its platform we have containers
homepage on cloud cool calm okay that's
awesome and finally let's finish off
talking about cube con what are you most
excited about doing or seeing here
yeah it's amazing how cute con is grown
I was at the very first cute con in 2015
and the panel onstage with some of the
other old-timers on the project I think
it was less than 500 people Wow
and it's just amazing to see how much it
has grown and and all the wonderful
things that people tell me that
communities is doing for them so that's
really the most gratifying thing to me
is that for the for the people who tell
me wow this totally not only made my job
better but thereby made my life better
now I'm not like doing all this grunge
work and it's taking us forever to
deploy you know we're actually able to
have much more impact on our business by
deploying much faster and it's much less
work for me so I can actually spend the
time doing what I want to do so it's
those stories that I love cool well
thank you very much for your time Brian
yeah have a good one
[Music]